climate change is about to upend the
corporate world
like never before
massive devastation it was a firestorm
heavy regulation the world's worst
emitting companies even the worst
medium emitting companies are on
borrowed time and
lots more litigation pg e's billion
dollar payout
on volkswagen pleading guilty in detroit
for cheating on emissions rules
covert 19 has highlighted the perils of
failing to prepare
the businesses refuse to change we will
go the way of the dinosaur
there's ash that is falling staving off
the catastrophe of climate change
requires a rewiring of the entire global
economy
this spells huge opportunities for some
the economic opportunity of this green
revolution
is not less than original natural
revolution
but can the corporate world react and
adapt
in time climate change is like cancer
the longer you wait the worse your
chances are
[Music]
we're driving through downtown saint
helena and you can see the smoke and
people's headlights the smoke is so
thick it's like a dense fog
lisa mckelly is a scientist who advises
businesses on the impact of wildfires
caused by climate change
within the past few weeks four out of
california's five biggest recorded
wildfires have smothered this famous
wine growing region with ash and smoke
the fire stops here
today lisa is advising dan petrovsky
winemaker at larkmead vineyards on how
to reduce its exposure to risks
down there
just three days ago fire burned right up
to the edge of these vineyards
that's what i call a hazard pulley
so what was it like when you first
headed towards larkman
there were five fire trucks on the other
side of this uh the river here it was
the heaviest smoke i've been
part of stinging my eyes also that that
night of the
power line went down and hit my car and
that's when i put out a fire over by the
winery and that's then i burned my
boots let's see those boots these are so
the rubber on the bottom of my uh
soles and my boots were this was
actually a fire at larkmead
uh on the property how high do you think
the flames got here
they were absolutely flamed straight up
um there was one that looked like
it was just like super ominous it was by
itself and it was just like
a lonely tree with just a straight fire
line
well this is a great example two of us a
place that is burned
but if another fire was to start there's
plenty left that could burn again
for lark mead this fire was a narrow
escape
but in a state that produces 86 of
america's wine
many other businesses have not been so
lucky
8 000 structures have been lost and
nearly
30 percent of the county of napa has
been consumed
in the 2020 fire season we are dealing
with constant power shutoffs
during the fire weather to try to avoid
fires from starting
so this of course is hitting a community
that's had
two years of fires and then the covid
crisis
and so our local businesses are
struggling
to stay alive
temperatures in excess of 35 celsius
spoil grapes and force vineyards to shut
down
just over a century ago napa county hit
these
temperatures on average six days a year
now
that figure is 33 days
the average temperature of the planet
has already risen by almost one degree
celsius since 1970.
climate models suggest that if this
reaches 2 degrees
the world's existing wine growing region
will shrink by 56
although i was exposed to the concept of
climate change
early in my career i never thought that
the impacts
we were projecting would come to pass in
my lifetime
our computer model said oh well maybe
it'll happen at the end of the century
you know 2050
2060 but we're here in 2020
and we're seeing some of the worst case
scenarios come to pass
the physical risks to businesses from
climate change stretch
far beyond the industry of winemaking
25th named storm of the season
it is the earliest j-named storm in
history
across the planet businesses of all
kinds are facing growing disruption from
more extreme
floods and storms research suggests
that climate change could cost 215 big
global firms a collective one trillion
dollars
much of this over the next five years
rich salkin is the co-founder of a
leading data analytics company
which advises firms on how to mitigate
these risks
the business community is facing more
risk from the weather
driven by climate change than ever
before
the statistics on this are crystal clear
the financial loss from weather-related
events
is at record levels and the impact has
been devastating
to protect societies and their
businesses from the worst effects of
climate change
more funds are needed for adaptive
measures from floating farms and storm
resilience seeds
to pop-up sea walls
according to one estimate around 180
billion dollars of investment
is required each year over the next
decade if you look
10 years forward there won't be a single
large entity on the planet commercial
or government that doesn't have
a well-thought-out approach to assessing
and addressing
physical risks from climate change it
looks a bit like
cyber security did 10 years ago where
businesses by and large were just
starting to realize there was an issue
but didn't know what to do about it
didn't have the tools to address it
now every major entity on the planet has
a
well thought out cyber security program
while they struggle to adapt to the
changing physical environment
companies also face a changing
regulatory landscape
and recent developments in the world's
two most polluting countries
mean this could come quicker than
expected
[Applause]
to save our planet by getting climate
under control
china is the world's largest polluter
but it's now vowed to go carbon neutral
the world's carbon emissions have jumped
in the past
three decades by more than 60 percent
over 70 percent of this pollution can be
traced back to just
100 companies mostly through the
products they sell such as oil or coal
leading climate scientist gavin schmidt
argues that governments will soon find
there is no option but to heavily
increase regulation on businesses
some companies have as large a carbon
footprint as
some small countries right so so they
have i think an equal responsibility
uh to to try and do something about the
problem
uh you know it's it's all well and good
trying to get somalia to change its
its policies but it's irrelevant in
terms of carbon uh but if you can get
walmart to change its policies or apple
or google
uh then you can do something much more
fundamental progress has been slow
since the 2015 international paris
agreement to keep global warming below 2
degrees
the un climate champion responsible for
working with business
believes it's time to force the pace
so collectively we're not moving fast
enough collectively we don't have enough
policy ambition
um and collector we don't have enough
business ambition this
is going to be regulated and you can't
just wait
until the regulations come and then
start changing it
there is pressure on governments to
bring in regulation of the corporate
world
now it's coming from consumers
and climate activists
and it's the focus of this extinction
rebellion protest in london
economic interests are prepared to
sacrifice your long-term future for
their short-term profit
[Music]
i think primarily everyone is here
protesting today because there's a real
sense of being let down
chidi is a former banker who is now
extinction rebellion spokesperson on
banks and the economy
it's profoundly important to bring
pressure to bear
on those larger players to change their
practice and set a good example
that everyone else can follow greenpeace
are involved
um friends of the earth were involved
there's several parties got together to
say
how do we make the government actually
keep to its promise yeah they declare
the climate change emergency and since
then
nothing's happened like many extinction
rebellion
argues one policy is crucial forcing
businesses to come
clean about their levels of emissions
lots of banks and lots of people want to
see
firms show the world they're real and
full
carbon footprint and trying to make that
happen as quickly as possible
as openly as possible is something that
xr is fighting for
but businesses refuse to change we will
go the way of the dinosaur
we will lose our habitats and
potentially lose our lives in numbers
and that's why groups like us are here
asking government to facilitate
a business environment that forces
businesses to change if need be
because the stakes are so high
[Music]
what that change will look like is an
obligation for companies to measure
as well as disclose their own emissions
nicolette bartlett
is director of an international
non-profit which advises corporations on
how to do this
the world's worst emitting companies
even the worst medium emission companies
are on borrowed time
carbon is very very costly to society
at some point that will hit their bottom
line
it's guaranteed so it is a big risk if
you're not
seeing it measuring it reporting it and
changing your business practice
most businesses are not prepared for
this transition
only sixteen percent of listed companies
currently calculate and disclose their
own
carbon footprint i think it's becoming
harder
for companies to greenwash i think more
and more because of this transparency
the investor world has
really woken up to this the central
banks have really woken up to this
consumers have really worked up to us
and actually joined covered even more so
it's not a marginal issue anymore it's
front and center
it's very difficult for companies to
hide
but some big corporations are now
jumping before they're pushed
and making big decarbonizing pledges
macrosoft has made a major climate
pledge
promising to go carbon negative amazon
will be one of the first companies about
the first company to meet the paris
climate accords ten years early what
we've seen
is even in the last year a doubling of
commitments from companies right
and they range they they may make a
claim around going to be carbon neutral
or they'll make a claim around i'm going
to be net zero by a certain date
the task of delivering on these pledges
is daunting
firms will have to disclose not just the
emissions they produce
but also those from their supply chains
which on average
are over five times bigger
that's a tall order for the likes of
walmart it's promised to cut a billion
tons of emissions between 2017 and 2030
covering 100 000 suppliers across the
world
its supply chain is massive
it's a very bold target so the next 10
years are going to be critical
i would argue that maybe now some of the
the lower hanging fruit the easier stuff
has been done in that supply chain
it's going to take a huge effort across
all of those supply chains
it's absolutely critical that you are
able to cover your entire
value chain
[Music]
ultimately it's the world's most
polluting companies that will be hit
hardest by carbon regulation and will
have to make the most drastic changes to
survive
in south yorkshire and britain once an
industrial heartland
heavy industries like coal mining have
died out
but at this steel plant in rotherham
climate change has provided a seemingly
unlikely opportunity for rejuvenation
through radical green adaptation it's
almost god's power
in your hands right it's such an awesome
feeling
now they're recycling steel here
according to the ceo this is half the
company's emissions in britain
and cut costs for the uk it's a
no-brainer
for the uk it is absolutely definitely
cheaper
to recycle steel than to make new steel
uh uk exports eight nine million tons of
steel scrap already and we export steel
scrap and import steel which was
made no sense at all so our model was
based on recycling
local steel scrap for the local market
which was a better economic model
for the long term the ceo says the
company is investing in green steel
which uses hydrogen to dramatically
reduce emissions
even though it could be two decades
before this technology is commercially
viable
hydrogen is like renewables it's only
just really starting its journey now
as we make more and more hydrogen that
technology will become cheaper and
cheaper
the same way as wind and solar
technology very expensive 10 years ago
and they become more and more
competitive as we adopted more and more
scale and as technology has developed
this journey to green still
is inevitable
and there lies a strong incentive for
businesses to adapt to climate change
it could actually be good business in
the long run
those who invest now in expensive
decarbonization
may steal a march on the competition we
know how industrial
transformation takes place it always
happens exponentially
and those who get the wrong side of the
curve can never catch up
and we see newcomers right who who bet
the farm on that transition
becoming the new industrial titans this
penny has dropped for some fossil fuel
companies
in an industry where profits could fall
from 39 trillion dollars
to 14 trillion by 2050
the danish company orsted has doubled
its share value by completely ditching
oil
in favor of renewables this building
that we're sitting in it's not just
about the energy it's uses to keep us
warm or cool how to put the lights on
but it's also about the materials that
made this building
is it more expensive at the beginning
yes but is that going to be a market for
the future 100
so i would say it's logical visionary
business practice
but if the carrot of long-term profits
doesn't incentivize companies to go
green
there's a stick that might force more
hands in the future
[Music]
the growing legal risks of failing to
adapt to climate change
have been highlighted by one utility
company in california
well today pg e is expected to plead
guilty to involuntary manslaughter for
the utility's role in the deadly camp
fire
in 2019 pacific gas and electric
pleaded guilty to one count of illegally
starting a fire
and 84 counts of involuntary
manslaughter
the deadliest corporate crime
successfully prosecuted in america
pg e power lines have helped start over
1500 wildfires in the past six years
in a region where rising temperatures
caused by climate change
have increased the risks around fires
courts have concluded the company failed
to invest in maintaining their equipment
and back in the wine country of napa
valley local businesses have paid the
price
when the doors burned the wine burned
behind it so i lost about
almost 17 000 bottles of wine here in
this tunnel here
one of them is the white rock vineyard
owned by christopher vandenrisch and his
family
this is my dad henry he's uh started
this
uh this version of white rock in the 70s
when he replanted the vineyards this is
one of the bottles that partially burned
in the fires
when you see that smoke coming in it's a
very visceral feeling it's horrible and
um traumatic in 2017
fires burned down every structure on
their property
i think that there needs to be a culture
change at pg e in order to
do a better job of maintaining the
networks that they
that they oversee and to reduce the
profit motive the courts have ordered
the company to pay out billions in
compensation
and pg e says it has changed his ways
i do think that many people who took
part in that case
feel vindicated our entire business
community
and utilities need to learn how to adapt
to a changing climate
exxon mobil has long been criticized for
allegedly hiding what it knew about
climate change
a growing number of companies are facing
legal proceedings linked to global
warming
from allegations of misleading investors
about climate risk
to public nuisance claims between 2000
and 2010
about 20 climate-related cases were
brought against businesses
but in the past decade that figure has
soared to around 120.
bankruptcy negligence indictments
loss of reputation all these terrible
awful things
are going to happen to more companies if
they don't wake up
and start addressing these issues
[Music]
lack of effective preparation for kovid
19
has contributed to devastation around
the world
it's highlighted the importance of
acting against climate change now
rather than waiting until the crisis
worsens
but few companies are heeding this
lesson
the longer we go without taking enough
action and the
harsher the course correction is then
the bigger the stranded assets will be
economically and at a human level do we
manage this
or do we screw it up the only choice in
front of us
is to lean into the the clean and the
green economy
not leaning in means economies that
could be so severely damaged
that what we see now as our global
capital market
would look fundamentally different this
is not an issue
that anybody who thinks that they're a
leader can just ignore
right this is a fundamental
challenge for this century and anybody
who thinks they can
sidestep it is not really leading at all
[Music]
hi my name is guys griffin i'm the
economist climate risk correspondent
if you'd like to read my special report
about business and climate change please
click on the link opposite
if you want to continue watching our now
next series click on the other link
thank you for watching and don't forget
to subscribe